[Musique]
il s'agit d' du festival au fil des voix
qui est organisé un pari à partir de la
fin janvier jusqu'à la mi-février et
nous accueillons l'avant première
nous avons noué un partenariat avec ce
festival pour
accueillir de gros artistes musiques du
monde là en l'occurrence nous recevrons
un artiste kurdes à la clé des champs en
configuration assise
[Musique]
on va avoir du ragga du métal du peuple
du rap de la chanson française donc
voilà
dans plusieurs directions tout en
gardant une identité qu'on va essayer de
développer
au fur et à mesure
[Musique]
avec bigard en kz1 tête d'affiche belle
artiste français ragga se déroulera le 9
avril on a eu la confirmation ce matin
l'occasion d'y revenir et ensuite on a
le 18 février une soirée 100%
brésilienne avec le théâtre coluche à
plaisir la clé des champs c'est aussi
les concerts hors les murs on appelle ça
les hanches en est donc là on accueille
joâo salua en première partie de flaviac
oui